hi I'm Ankur Kotwal and I'm an Android
developer advocate hi I'm Alex Danilo
and I'm a chrome developer advocate
today we want to talk to you about some
new developer features that we've added
in the webview on Android so more
specifically Android 4.4 also known as
KitKat introduced an updated webview
which is actually built off the chromium
webview now and that brings a whole
range of new features for developers
that's right anchor in fact what we've
built now into the webview is all the
functionality of Chrome so what that
means to you as a developer is that you
have all the html5 capabilities that
exist in Chrome shifted into the webview
so you can take advantage of modern
html5 and all its API is just kind of
nice
absolutely so let's have a look at a
demo
well before we should go into the demo I
just wanted to point out something that
one thing that's been really hard for me
as developer is actually debugging stuff
in a webview like I mean how do you do
bug normally when you're building
Android applications I use Android
studio or eclipse right like I used to
as well but you know when I'm developing
on the desktop I use you know chrome dev
tools which really makes my life simple
and now you can actually do it from the
webview so why don't we just have a look
at how we actually go about doing that
what I have here is we have like a
little full you know full screen game
and it's you know you hit the start
button here and what you have is like a
ball that you can roll around okay so
it's a kind of a standard thing but what
I'd like to point out here is that we're
actually using the motion in the device
to control the ball we couldn't do that
before could we anchor no so this is now
the accelerometer and the the chromium
web view is is mapping that Hardware
accelerometer on your Android device
straight through to the webview itself
so this is a demo that that Alex you
built and we're now this app here is
effectively it's a web app it's it's
just a thin wrapper of an app that drops
in a webview and it's a just logged into
your site isn't it exactly and so the
beauty of this is that you know now we
have this webview and in the old days
prior to KitKat you'd be thinking how do
i do bug this it's really hard but
what I can do is and come over here to
Chrome and I can just go over and have a
look at chrome inspect if I go and have
a look at that you'll suddenly see the
devices that are connected to my laptop
visible and here we actually see we've
got a nexus 10 running this application
at the moment and you can see the actual
webview itself so you know for Android
developers you'd be familiar with this
you know kondal Alex roller so that's
the namespace my apps been developed in
so all I have to do is click this
inspect link and lo and behold we have
the full chrome dev tools experience
identical to what happens on a desktop
but now it's actually talking into the
device and I can look at the Dom I can
break point JavaScript I can modify the
Dom on the fly so then this is not a
special build of your app right nice
when you drag and release builds exactly
that's the beauty of it this is for any
app that uses the chrome webview now
which is fantastic so I can drill down
look in the Dom here and of course I can
see the start button but there's no
there's no game content you can see
hovering over it it's actually changing
what you can see on the screen so if I
actually tap the start to start the game
you see all of a sudden all these new
elements appear in the Dom so this is a
live Don actually on the fly and if you
have a look at down here the very bottom
which I have that highlighted you can
see the rotation and the transforms are
changing on the fly so as the ball is
moving around this is actually changing
live so this is just fantastic
although Android like I don't know like
the holes that the ball falls into
they're a bit dark for me what do you
think yeah I mean all of our UX research
shows that you should use lighter colors
Alex I think you're right so why don't
we do that why don't we actually change
the color that we're seeing so if I go
back up the top since I actually wrote
this I know what to look at but there's
my Senses SVG that's also a newer
feature of the chromium webview right
exactly right Viji support that's right
well we brought brought enos SVG support
I think it was honeycomb was the first
version that supported it but now the
webview actually has it and it has a you
know and it flies so I've got these
gradients here that are used for the
holes so if you have a look that he's
this gradient that's black and gray
I might just decide that I'd prefer the
holes to be blue you know start is blue
so if you actually watch as I change
that all the holes suddenly
change to blue so we're actually
modifying the live DOM and this is like
an incredible feature so the ball itself
let's go down to the ball let me have a
look you'll notice we have a chrome logo
there on the on the ball right see
that's a chrome logo spinning around
which is controlled by this image here
now I could actually just select it and
delete it and lo and behold our ball has
become a blue ball because I've taken
away that image and this is like really
bad because now we can't tell the ball
from the holes so we can actually change
the color of that circle that is the
ball and it becomes red and we can again
see what it looks like so there you have
it we have actual live editing on the
fly of our web app without any code
changes and you can do this from your
desktop from your laptop on the fly I
mean it's just an awesome new feature in
KitKat and we should also add that when
we connected with Chrome we didn't need
ADB or the developer tools installed
it's all built into chrome now and you
can connect directly it just shows up
that's exactly right
pro tip for all the developers out there
turn on hardware acceleration because
that will make your apps fly with the
new view so hardware acceleration html5
features
I love KitKat it's fantastic thank you